she shouldn't be touching him but does
so anyway
only nine days old baby Amir has already
survived a tear gas attack
his mother's hand won't harm him she
says it's to give him a sense of safety
a sign that she's there for him
and why I saw videos showing attacks by
Israeli forces on hospitals in Janine
scared and helpless she wanted to be
there with her baby but she couldn't get
to him
I was sad and worried all the time since
the invasion to the camp started I
couldn't be around him I couldn't hold
him to my chest or even see him I hope
no mother ever goes through what I went
through
misal had an area close to the hospital
Witnesses say snipers opened fire on
people on the hospital's grounds and
fired tear gas into the emergency room
One landed in the nursery
there was no Escape
I moved the babies away from the windows
and closer to one another nurse
majdulillah cared for the crying babies
she says it's amazing they survived
she cannot guarantee their development
hasn't been affected by the attack
they're vulnerable even a knock on their
incubators could affect babies and wake
them up we consider it a stressor
imagine the sound of bullets tear gas
and invasions it was a difficult scene
some of these babies were born to
parents who witnessed the large Israeli
assault on the Janine refugee camp 20
years ago they fear that their children
will also face a future filled with
anxiety fear and uncertainty
baby Isla was released from the nursery
after Israeli forces withdrew from the
refugee camp
she suffered breathing problems her
mother says what was supposed to be the
safest place for her turned into one of
the worst
I can't wait for her to leave the
hospital the staff was amazing but I
feel so scared I don't want her away
from me
they say their babies are strong
and lucky but the parents of Isla and
Amir know their experience of Israel's
military occupation is just beginning
they only wish it hadn't started so soon
the occupied West Bank